how're you doing today sir I'm doing
excellent uh I want to start by saying
your work in this film is tremendous
Thanks
what was I have to I spoke to Willem
previously and he said to me this was a
effing challenging shoot would you
describe the same thing yeah it's funny
I keep thinking cuz I because I like the
movie it's funny that when he when he
let bang got it that's that if I didn't
like the maybe a bit ah like but I think
there's there's something about the
physical and elemental challenges of
something if they are the same
challenges your characters experiencing
but it's kind of it never felt that bad
like if you if you if it's freezing cold
then you have to play but it's not
freezing cold then it's a really
miserable experience but you're kind of
if you could lean into every single
environmental challenge that came up for
this that's actually it was kind of sad
it was pretty satisfying uh one of the
things that I think is so cool is that
he used old cameras old lenses to
capture this time in place when did he
first tell you he wanted to do that and
what was it like using that vintage
equipment I knew it was in the script I
said it was gonna be in mono and it was
gonna be on black and white negative and
then a spur and the Academy aspect ratio
but I didn't know about the lenses and
stuff until we did the test and is I
mean it was quite it was kind of
shocking to see how much light you need
to use cuz I hadn't had any idea and
when you basically got a spotlight where
people were getting sunburned from the
amount of light and that's to shoot at
night scene I think I mean his thing
I've seen that but I looked so cool I
mean I kind of when I saw the first
couple of stairs coming back wow that is
not I didn't even know like what the
filter could achieve that just taking
out the Reds in someone's face
you just look crazy after
yeah so it was video I was fasting I
don't think I have a minute and it's so
ambitious as well I mean it--not one
else is gonna be the kind of make you
maybe the list I just know what
completely
what was your listen you've done such
fantastic work recently in a number of
previous films what was it about this
script when you first read it that said
I absolutely have to do this I mean it's
pretty strikingly original and also I
kind of like the scripts where you're
reading in you're like is this supposed
to be funny like I don't really know
it's it's like is this does he know does
Robert know how crazy this is and it's
kind of and I kind of I love that area
of humor where you're kind of I mean
until I still the first screams I mean
we had no idea if people will get a
laugh oh no and when I heard them when I
was standing outside the screening care
and people were laughing I was like well
people get it and yeah I mean I love
that kind of weird playing with tones
where it's kind of like this is a horror
movie is this really dark comedy is this
kind of surrealistic nightmare they I
mean there was a lot of elements and
also I mean on top of that incredibly
period to period correct dialect and it
was obviously been really researched and
there's just it was just quite
overwhelming script the dialogue is
amazing I already got to go I'm just
gonna say grats on everything man and
congrats on booking Nolan thank you
that's all